hey guys welcome to lesson seven so this
is the final lesson of the course and in
this lesson I'm going to be talking much
more around the AI safety side of things
so so far we've spoken about
fundamentals we've spoken about how to
build AI systems ourselves but now we're
going to be talking about how we can
actually deploy those or Implement them
safely and in accordance with the
different rules and the regulations that
are being uh released around the world
now so I'm basically going to explain
the current environment in terms of
regular ations today um and how that
could potentially change in the future
I'm also going to talk about data
privacy rules which obviously apply to
AI systems as well um and at the end of
this uh the key takeaway will be you can
kind of audit your own solutions that
you could be building and also some
solutions which you might be using from
third parties um from software providers
so this will be the key takea away from
this lesson and without further Ado
let's get
started so to get started I want us to
head over to our notion training page
and I want you to scroll down to lesson
s and open this so in this lesson I'm
going to be talking about both the
current regulations and also on the
developing regulations so I'm going to
avoid doing too much speculation but
talking just about the laws um all the
regulations which are currently being
debated um and where those are today so
I'm going to do this by going around
different regions in the world and
talking about where only where the AI
regulations already exist or where
they're being discussed or debated at
the moment with some some road towards
some regulations being
passed so um to get started this is a
map of the world where every um region
which has uh AI regulations today since
2016 um is mapped so you can see here
the a the scale is like 0 to 10 plus and
each country here we can see is the
number of uh AI related bills or
regulations that have been passed so you
see there's a lot happening in North
America also um Russia and China have
some and Europe there's not not not to
say other places don't have any yet you
can see that there are some emerging but
these are the main centers for where the
most uh AI regulations have been passed
recently but many countries around the
world are now discussing these
regulations so let's just get started
with Europe because they've just passed
some quite notable AI regulations
earlier uh this year in
2024 so basically um they've just
recently passed this AI act so you can
click this link to read uh into that act
itself but what I've uh written down
here is basically a summary for both on
the AI developer side and also the AI
user side uh in terms of what this act
really means so basically this AI act um
applies to all AI systems which are
being used within the EU regardless of
where the developer is based it also
includes free to use AI um
technology and what they've basically
done here is they've um assumed a risk
uh based approach so what this means is
that um if you're developing an AI
Solution that's either for a high-risk
area such as like for example education
law enforcement migration um anything
like this they're subject to like more
scrutiny these AI models so um also in
terms of uh unacceptable risk so um the
idea here is that they're checking to
see if the systems could potentially
manipulate um Behavior exploit
vulnerabilities or perhaps mislead or
cause confusion at like a huge scale so
this is their approach is more if you're
building something for an industry or an
application which they consider as being
high risk
then it will be subject to like more
scrutiny so the idea here is it's more
just around risk assessments I would say
um so essentially these AI developers on
the developer side would need to
implement these risk management systems
and show those to the regulator also
around data governance um what's going
into the data sets um maintaining the
technical documentation so having
upto-date technical documentation
explaining what the how the AI system
works or how it's to be used um having
human oversight so they don't want fully
autonomous systems they want someone who
is kind of keeping an eye on that or a
human in the loop um it's called
sometimes so um the idea here is around
more audit an approach for being
audited so um yeah there's like some
very high fines here for non-compliance
so 35 million or 7% of global Revenue
and I would say generally I I think that
the key takeaway from this is that this
is more applying to Big tech companies
who are developing foundational models
um but this doesn't mean to say things
that we develop um on a more like
smaller scale uh wouldn't be subject to
these these uh the scrutiny um but yeah
a key takeaway is essentially that The
Regulators in the EU can ENT do a
Conformity assessment or an audit of
this technology so the idea here is that
this could happen this would happen like
regularly and these um technology
providers need to have this
documentation in place and be able to
explain how their systems work to
regulators and if they don't comply with
that then it would be a fine so it's
more around having this information
management system in place um and
ensuring that the systems like that's
being used is not manipulating Behavior
exploiting vulnerabilities Etc okay now
more for the user side so if you're
using an AI system I think one of the
most key things to be aware of is that
you legally in the EU now you have to be
told when you're interacting with an AI
system so that that company that or um
whoever's developed that AI system needs
to tell the users that that's what it is
um it can't be like opaque or
um these users can't be unaware of that
fact so that's the key one I would say
but there's also you know in fact in
terms of like respecting human
fundamental rights uh obviously um and
this should be human oversight so
providing users with the ability to
understand and control the ai's decision
making process so um that's quite
interesting one I won't dive into this
some discussion right now but yeah data
protection is also a P1 we're going to
talk about this a little bit more but
yeah in the um data protection laws in
the EU also appli to AI systems as
well in terms of the US so there's been
a lot of um discussion around AI
regulations in the US um and most of the
regulations that are in place right now
in the US are more encouraging more
around encouraging R&D spending in AI
such as maintain the bill which is
maintaining American leadership in AI so
um this is like a federal uh passed on
the federal level and this is more to um
yeah encourage more R&D rather than
regulating how the technology is being
used um but there are some proposed
regulations which uh include like the
algorithmic accountability act which are
focused on providing transparency around
AI algorithms so to put that into
perspective Give an example this is in
some cases so social media apps where
they use an algorithm to push content to
users and so they um this this
regulation will allow an audit of AI
systems um including those algorithms
for Content pushing content to users um
in order to check that those algorithms
are like safe or unbiased or trustworthy
in some way um but the this this uh bill
is yet to be passed so this is being
debated at the moment next if we talk
about Canada so Canada is actually
currently advancing the AI and data act
which is um a set of regulations which
are aimed at safeguarding the Canadian
citizens from high-risk AI systems and
uh promoting the responsible development
of AI so um again this is I guess looks
like it could be kind of similar to what
the EU has um implemented um and you can
read a bit more about the ACT using this
link um but this has not been passed yet
and they've do have some regulations
though but these are more aimed at um
the federal level which uh so the
government um that they need to adere to
when creating these automated
decisionmaking systems so you could
think of this as a way that in which
they've already implemented a AI
regulations but it's just um applying to
governments the government sector like
public
services uh Brazil is also um looking
into passing a comprehensive AI act so
they have their own bill that's been
debated at the moment and this seeks to
basically prit some high-risk AI systems
so again kind of similar to the eu's
philosophy um around around um risk uh
having like a risk-based approach so
next up we have China so China actually
has very comprehensive AO regulations
already I think they have more today
than any other country in the world um I
won't talk specifically about each one
of these different regulations but
there's a link here if you'd like to uh
read more about these but I will talk
about what this means for AI developers
and users what these regulations mean so
basically if you're an AI developer and
you're building for the Chinese market
then you uh need to know that there's a
list of restricted areas where um these
AI Solutions aren't allowed to to um
either have like knowledge of those or
to um solve problems in those areas so
there's like a a kind of restricted
areas list um yeah there's also um the
this need for third party evaluation so
you could think of this as being a bit
similar to like the EU EU regulations as
well in the sense that these AI models
can undergo regular evaluations by third
party organizations like including the
public sector
um and they should be prepared for
external audits to check and verify the
AI
technology so again this like regulatory
oversight and audits um yeah this this
like I there's quite lenient approach to
like IP um IP enforcement in China
meaning that um there's more
encouragement on AI development than
around around uh stringent IP
regulations so they're more just trying
to encourage I'd say the techn ology to
like flourish rather than over more IP
considerations um then yeah basically
another thing to to think about is more
on the user side I I won't discuss too
much on these two um but more on the
user side so users can basically um
expect the um the content to be like
traceable to know where information came
from so like references and sources for
when information is being prevented uh
being provided and the idea here is to
prevent
misinformation um yeah so to be able to
trace back to this s of original
verified Source um in terms of um like
the country's like verified information
then data protection so again these uh
data protection laws apply to the AI
applications as well you also have a law
around algorithm decision making so um
basically like greatest scrutiny over
recommendations or decision making
within like the public sector so these
would be under more
scrutiny um and I won't talk about this
final one really but um yeah this they
have a comprehensive set of regulations
here they have quite a lot next up is
India so India uh doesn't have uh
specific a regulations just now but they
have an upcoming digital India act which
is set to focus on again more high-risk
AI applications so um once again
choosing this kind of um AI risk
assessment approach so just targeting
more the high-risk systems which seems
to be I guess quite a global Trend now
which um many countries are looking
into um and they've also set up recently
A specialized task force which is for
specifically delving into AI ethical
legal societal aspects um and again I
think the idea here is more encouraging
AI development within India more more so
than um more so than like regulating it
too heavily next is Japan so Japan don't
actually have strict AI regulations but
what they do have is um guidelines so
they've created a set of guidelines in
terms of um M managing and developing AI
Solutions so the key documents are the
guidelines for implementing AI
principles and this AI governance
document so less less on the strict
regulations more on guidance um
Australia hasn't also hasn't introduced
specific AI governance laws or policies
but they are looking into it um and
they're leveraging some current
regulations and potentially adapting
those more to AI um oversight but
nothing confirmed yet more in the early
stages of some discussions next we'll
talk briefly about global privacy laws
so first we're going to talk about what
this means for AI developers so the
different Global uh different privacy
laws from around the world uh and then
after we've gone through those we'll
talk about from the user perspective
what that means what your rights are as
a user of these AI
systems so first we'll start talking
about one of the earliest data privacy
laws that was passed which was the gdpr
in the EU and this applies to any
organization processing personal data of
EU residents so these rules apply
globally
um when the users are EU
residence and the key the key elements
of the gdpr is minimizing the amount of
data you're collecting so apps shouldn't
be collecting more data than they need
um also they should be protecting data
so they should have inbuilt security
privacy uh rules so that this data isn't
being shared um with those the user
isn't aware of or which aren't essential
to the service
um also accountability and compliance so
you should actually maintain records of
how you're handling the data your
systems for handling data um and logs as
well of how data has been moved around
there are penalties for non-compliance
so these can be huge so like 20 million
EUR or 4% of global turnover so really
big penalties for not complying with
these laws um in terms of the US there's
some notable data privac laws which
apply to California residents in
particular which are quite similar to
gdpr in the sense that users actually
have a right to know what data is being
collected they have a right to request
the data to be deleted right to opt out
and again um penalties but not as high
as the gdpr
penalties Singapore also has a similar
similar setup where by um basically this
applies to all private sector
organizations so not public sector um
and where they're collecting personal
data and these key Provisions are that
um basically organizations must obtain
consent before collecting personal data
and the data should be just limited to
what is the service that's being
delivered you need to have a data
Protection Officer so this is someone
who's in charge of managing the data
within the organization and there are
some Hefty fines for non-compliance so
up to a million Singapore dollars for
non-compliance
uh Brazil has data privacy laws which um
apply also to organizations handling
personal data for Brazilian residents
and um these laws are quite similar to
gdpr as well in terms of right to access
correction deletion of data and um
organizations basically have to notify
authorities as well anytime there's been
a data breach so they can't uh keep this
uh hushed up or secret they have to
notify authorities and there's a hefty
finds as well for for
non-compliant basically for the user
side so um users have a right to access
their personal data change it erase it
so you can write to a company and say I
want you to delete all my data and they
have to do that um in accordance with
the gdpr rules um they can the the data
they request has to be in a nice format
it can't just be a dump it has to be
machine
readable um and um yeah they can also
object or or um decline certain types of
um data processing so they have a right
to that um California residents they
have a right to know what data has been
collected a right to delete it and they
also interestingly have this right to
not be discriminated against for
exercising their privacy rights so if
they don't want to provide data they
can't this can't be like held against
them in some way it's quite an
interesting
um Rule and then the pdpa in Singapore
again you have a right to access a right
to correct data and you also have a
right to withdraw your content for the
data collection and the use so um again
you you don't have to provide all this
personal data when using some
Services uh Brazil again you'll see this
is quite a pattern so right to access
correction deletion um moving your data
in a portable format and um your right
to know so basically to request
information about data processing that's
happening from a company okay so guys
this brings us to the end of this lesson
um so in this lesson obviously what
we've covered is the rules and
regulations and what this means on the
side for you if you're building these AI
systems you need to be aware of um
potentially some rules that mean you
have to build in ways of deleting and
wiping that personal data from users how
you can send it to them if they request
it how you can uild this like privacy
privacy and safety rules um into your
systems so these are the things you
should be aware of on the Builder side
and obviously as a user you know kind of
what your rights are in terms of using
these systems um and what the the
solution providers should be doing in
terms of building Safe Systems that
you're using so these are the things to
be aware of and this also brings us to
the end of the course so I hope you've
enjoyed this and what I really want you
to do now is to go ahead and start
thinking about your final project which
is going to be the culmination of
everything you've learned on this course
and I hope that you feel inspired to
potentially take one of the templates
we've already created or build your own
and submit this as a final project and
send it into the Discord group that we
have the community of over 300 other
Engineers um and construction
professionals from around the world and
see what they think of the solution
you've developed yourself so I hope you
feel um INSP ired and um excited to
build your own solution um at the end of
this course and thank you very much for
joining us and I hope you enjoyed it
enjoyed it and speak to you again next
time